how can you have 56% of Americans in
support of fully ending the drug war and
0 senators in support of it
hi I'm Tracy Oppenheimer for even TV I'm
here with Doug fine investigative
journalist and author of too high to
fail cannabis in the new green economic
revolution Doug thanks for being here
thanks so much for having me Tracy could
you give us some numbers some facts and
figures about the size and scope of the
industry and where the money is going
right now any time there's a prohibition
economy crime and organized crime tends
to be the profit makers so we have these
super rich cartels most estimates plate
so many percent of cartel profits coming
from cannabis what I did was I followed
the one place at the time in the US
where the local government had said this
is what our economy is here of us in
Mendocino County California within that
one County in the year that the federal
government allowed it to really fully
operate 2011 the program overall
generated $600,000 worth of revenue for
the county saved 7 deputy jobs and
mapped that on to an entire US and it
would be billions and billions for the
legitimate economy while taking while
crippling the cartels
talk about more how - Ino has special
conditions for this industry and why you
think it should serve as a model for the
rest of the country
I picked Mendocino because politically
and culturally it was ready the sheriff
had this revelation and he's not in his
own words he doesn't like to be thought
of as the Cheech & Chong's sheriff it's
not like he's out there just saying
do whatever you want he is a law and
order guy and he woke up one day after
legalizing medical cannabis in
California in 1996 and said guess what
they're still in America and everything
is fine and I think maybe people who
need to fight the drug war need to
retire and I need to generate this
revenue because we have budget cuts here
the government there does board of
supervisors said let's do this let's
stop the nonsense let's stop pretending
the elephant and the economy isn't there
and I'm just stop it and it worked but
nobody told the feds I think you said
it's 80% of the economy up there oh yeah
easily and I think that culture probably
isn't a flat
did as much of the rest of the country
do you think that the rest of the
country can still take notes from it
middle America seems really ready to end
the drug war we were getting eighty to
ninety percent of Americans pulling in
support of medical cannabis and over
fifty now of pushing 56% and increasing
and accelerating supporting just
flat-out regulating cannabis like
alcohol ending the drug war in that at
least in that regard
that's not a northern California issue
it's not a Democrat or a Republican
issue it's America sees that this
longest most expensive war is hurting us
that's hurting our economy especially
aside from medical marijuana a lot of
opponents to flat-out legalization say
it's different from alcohol prohibition
because it's not a cultural or social
staple like alcohol was so what do you
think about that I really fundamentally
disagree with that first of all on the
economic side it's an even bigger player
and it's a bigger crop already even
though everything is underground it's a
bigger crop than corn and wheat combined
it's an up America's number one cash
crop as far as those cultural tags I
don't know maybe that would have been
true in the 1950s but that cliche along
with the this is your brain on drugs
nonsense is passe and wrong and then
again back to the economic side prior to
alcohol prohibition in the late 1800s a
times alcohol before the income tax
alcohol taxes provided up to seventy
percent of federal revenue for better or
for worse so this can't be dismissed as
sort of a niche crop an issue that
wouldn't have a big economic impact it
actually has a chance to be a major
major major player in our economy you're
stressing cannabis is the word so can
you sort of say what that encompasses
instead of just saying marijuana the
reason I choose the term cannabis is
that it encompasses all the uses and the
industrial ones may one day dwarf the
psychoactive ones if we start using it
for fermentation for our energy needs it
can produce great biofuels as I said
already cannabis is in the bumpers of
dodge vipers so it's got great
industrial uses and I couldn't believe
that when I read it I had to call the
company and ask them and it's true so
that's why I use cannabis is that the
plant
a broad spectrum of uses all beneficial
as far as I'm concerned and you know in
Mendocino you said that the farmers
there are more than willing to succumb
to taxation and regulation but it seems
like their black market or the black
market provides a more profitable option
there are a lot of second or third
generation farmers that I spoke to in
the Emerald triangle as they call it up
there who are actually happy with the
status quo there's an organization
called the Emerald Growers Association
in Mendocino and humble and Trinity
counties that where they're setting
their own rules for certification what
we would call organic standards fair
trade standards because they believe
that's a marketing tool and that one day
they'll be on the shelves at Whole Foods
and and then there may be some people
that want cores or budweis they were you
know they may want something that's a
little bit different but their leaves
they'll be a shakedown after prohibition
ends and what drug war ends but that's
what capitalism is in the market will
prevail and I once the market does
prevail what what is this utopian
marijuana or cannabis and rich Society
look like for yes so I wouldn't say that
it's a utopia but understanding that
predictions are always risky if we go by
history and look about what happened
with alcohol prohibition when it ended I
think in the end especially if we allow
craft cannabis top shelf craft cannabis
the way we now allow microbrews we have
this multi-billion dollar micro brew
revolution that occurred when the
brewing rules changed in the 1970s we
will see significant reductions in our
use of foreign oil and we will see
actual use rates of various substances
go down because the people can be more
honest so I think that health ins will
see the declines of cartel profits I
spoke to a USDA biologist who was
involved in alternative fuels that's her
specialty and she was about to give a
talk on all these cool biofuels that are
better than corn and soy in terms of per
acre productivity and she was talking
about this plant called a trophy and
there's grape seed oil and I said what
about cannabis / hemp and she said oh
best one of all but we can't even we
can't even do it we can't even talk
about it because it's a federal crime LA
City Council voted to ban dispensaries
here the feds are obviously
very anti any sort of cannabis so what
what are the other barriers that we have
to overcome to get there Gary Johnson is
a former former governor of my state of
New Mexico he he calls the banning of
cannabis and the drug war the greatest
disconnect between America and her
politicians how can you have 56 percent
of Americans in support of fully ending
the drug war and 0 senators in support
of it there's some screwy thing that has
to do I think with bureaucratic inertia
when you've got billions going a lot of
people's jobs depend on it and we've got
to shift those billions into a different
place and get the Senate on board so I
think with that tipping point is going
to be when Americans get on the horn
with their politicians and say this is
actually a real issue you need to deal
and the drug war now great oh thank you
Doug for reason TV I'm Tracy Oppenheimer
you